[Music]
that's right oh my god dude how do you
do that I mean that was a wire gag for
sure crap so what they did is big thanks
to our flagship sponsor Squarespace for
bringing you today's episode stick
around to the end to find out how you
can get 10% off your first purchase hi
welcome back to stud men react here with
Eric Linden he's joined us again to give
us some great insight into the world of
stunts and some crazy things you guys
may not have heard stories of it's gonna
be I think it's gonna be a good one but
yeah sorry you comfortable yeah god I
sure wish you guys had a bigger couch
here say no more whoo yeah all right
this is great
Oh Eric's also back to set Clint on fire
now this video is probably to come out
always after that one but if you haven't
seen it you should definitely go check
that out okay
[Applause]
[Music]
that's right oh my god
[Music]
[Applause]
that's awesome dude cops information
they're just driving on the street I got
the whole time waiting pull out in front
of them so cool yeah imagine it's really
easy to lose it and like just a hundred
percent they have to have a highly
souped-up car to be able to do these
types of slides a lot of times the
stuffs tested in like say a parking lot
or on a track when you get out into the
real street like that you have manholes
different variations into concrete and
everything else you have to get some
people that are like the best in the
business some of these slides I mean
he's pushing this so far it's like
unbelievable with the car coming that
close to camera look right feet that's
like three to four feet away are there
are there like stunts camera guys I'm
assuming that this was a pursuit vehicle
and it has this massive Russian arm type
thing on top of it these guys are
stuntmen in their own right the guy who
is operating that Russian arm really
knows where he can be he can kind of
pull it up and the car will go
underneath it when you pull that off you
would expect to like jump out of the car
and be like yeah well that's what's so
great about a lot of these amazing
stuntmen directors like cut that was
amazing way to go we're gonna do it
again he just gets on the radio he's
like a copy going back to one like this
guy gnarly driving
[Music]
[Applause]
so are those puddles there so that he
can lose traction on the car absolutely
the puddles are actually like fairly
strategically placed so that he can lose
traction in a certain point and kind of
get it back and then with the back the
other direction away yeah so like that's
pretty slick but how much says those
trucks aren't there oh that's a good
point
that's right there the one that's
backing up yeah it's so close yeah it's
not almost looks like it goes straight
through it the back of that truck looks
pretty seedy it does look pretty CG but
you don't tell in motion yeah thought
the trucks there like the move that this
guy is doing is insane because I like it
he's got these walls that he can still
hit and he's able to even pull that off
there's nothing like a stuntman look
I've gotten familiar with like when
there's like bunch of dudes like holding
guns I'm like okay there's this stuntman
better hope he comes to that door and
not somewhere else
bullets are jam that's like the closest
batteries ever come to using a gun right
there we just cats batting in the back
of the head I love that they grab his
cape the worst thing that you can have
is a the vigilante escape you stab that
guy yeah yeah I think so this is a beefy
fight see Oh beefy see you have this
inherent problem where you need to get
rid of people's guns and I think it was
a pretty creative way to use one of his
gadgets to kind of like disarm as many
of them as he could dude how do you do
that I'm gonna go with it that is some
sort of like super hard rubber or
something but there's a little bit of
padding underneath it see how he's kind
of prepped for it and his knees are bent
he kind of is not jumping in the air
he's just rotating straight to the floor
I think that he actually did go for that
for the most part and he's a nasty stunt
man I'm sure he was like yeah we're
going for it we want the shot to be sick
now here we are talking about it like
mission accomplished
does it make impact softer to break
through stuff totally so that guy didn't
go through the wall just bounced off it
that'd be a bigger hit than going
through the wall
I think crashing through something
softens it a bit the definitely looks
cooler crashing through something oh
yeah
well it's nice to see Batman get thrown
to the ground because he's always just
you know kind of like kicking the crap
out of everybody and to see him get
overwhelmed and how he deals with it and
gets back to his feets pretty great
when building a fight scene on set I've
ever had the actor actually connect with
her face oh yeah definitely when we were
doing the daredevil Punisher fight I
mean me and the stunt guide from
daredevil definitely punched each other
in the face couple times but ends up
looking great so we definitely clipped
each other a couple of times but we
laughed that oh my god I'm so sorry I'm
so sorry you're also kind of like
pulling your punch too so like if you
clip somebody it's it may not be like
taking a MMA punch or something so we
actually look at the stats for these
videos in like 60% of the viewers who
watch these videos aren't subscribed to
the channel if you would consider
subscribing it actually helps us out it
helps the channel grow and it's a great
way to take the fate of your video
watching habits out of the hands of the
algorithm do you want a robot telling
you what to watch or do you want to
decide what you watch remember the movie
hot rod yeah
remember when he's falling down that
hill
I mean that was a wire dad for sure yeah
how how are they not breaking Ray's
doing this man I think that one was a
wire gag if you look at like the lone
survivor whether they're going down the
hill those guys just did that I mean
they did it kind of sections of it at a
time but all those hits were just you
know those guys Pat it up and went for
it a lot of that's that guy just just
launching him so off-screen they
probably have like a large pad or
something like that so that like his
momentum he can stop and not hit a tree
or get really hurt I mean they have to
be so sore the next day
[Music]
looks like his leg was backwards I mean
that guy won a stunt award for that
really in that stunt he was supposed to
make it yeah he actually didn't make it
and the stunt guy got hurt pretty good I
actually had a chance to meet Andy
Samberg like two months ago
oh really asked him about the scene that
really dude the dude cracked his femur
yes you saying that the first ramp is
supposed to collapse and the guy hits
the side of the truck that was what was
planned and you watch to the scene it
collapses but the guy has so much speed
he goes over and Clips the other side of
the ramp with his leg crap practice
femur every onset was like oh oh no we
have the rule if somebody hurts
themselves use a shot apparently the
Lonely Island guys are the same rule and
they use that shot in the phone
I heard that Patrick Swayze got like
really into skydiving first movie he was
skydiving before this oh really you know
they get to when they want to film this
and Swayze wants to jump like he wants
to do it on his own you know for
production reasons they absolutely would
not let him jump so what they did is on
one weekend Swayze literally was like
good buddies with the stunt coordinator
second unit director and some of those
guys and like that shot right there they
him and his buddies literally just took
the camera and did this rogue likes off
so they got all this footage of Swayze
jumping out of it on their own time
that's absolute gold that's amazing you
can clearly see it Tim you can clearly
see that's kyani like on some blue
screen and whatever man this is a lot
about like your passion for filmmaking
these scenes would not be nearly as
memorable without like the actual actors
flying around and then I mean that's
actually what happens when you get shot
you know people take these huge
reactions like the bullet just goes
through you pretty much don't move
unless I would say it's like a super
high caliber round from like a rifle or
something like that yeah but it looks
awesome like I'm all for it I love that
that's awesome I love how he wipes his
face off yeah that's bull send out the
door
is the great ketchup Massacre like a
gallon of milk just so good
I wish all movie squids were like that
there's a thing that Digital blood hits
like never can do as much as I love John
wick I you know it's like I wish they
would do a little bit more practical
blood and stuff like that I mean
typically with the squib special effects
guys gonna talk to you and be like hey
you know it's this much of a charge he's
gonna say it's gonna feel like you know
a light punch or it's gonna feel like
somebody flicking you like just
depending on how much is in there and
you'll get like a pad or you know you
can take a flat knee pad and put it
underneath there yeah and it should
protect you from that the first time we
did squibs we learned that you can't
have people's arms in front of them yeah
there's a little bit of what like
gunpowder in there and it can literally
like burn your arm it's hard though with
a gun fight scenes ever he's aiming or
shooting their guns and they're gonna
take center-of-mass hits it's gonna
blast into your arm so you know it's
like when those guys open the door no
it's like there's one guy just standing
there like this with the gun in his hand
just like wide open like no one has
their arms in front of their chests or
like the getting shot the shoulders
they're like way over here I love all
the backlighting - most people don't
know you need a like backlight squibs to
get them to show up both sides oh yeah
do the entry-and-exit squib that's like
the classiest squib look at this girl
just waiting for her
ratchet I can I can almost guarantee
that the stunt coordinator was like look
this completely defies all physics and
it makes zero sense whatsoever
go ahead Tarantino he's like I want to
do this and like okay I mean I almost
was just like yanked her into the
doorway and had her clip off of it what
makes it funny is that it's so fast
she's there and then she's not yeah you
know yo too long if you would like to
follow Eric's work ask him questions he
can follow him at Eric Linden did you
get overwhelmed last time I did you know
what I promised I would respond to
everybody I responded well over three
messages oh my god I get a lot of how do
I get started in stunts how did I
personally start so I literally just for
you guys went and typed up a manifesto
if you will on my website and I've been
firing that link to people just have
pure efficiency thanks guys yeah thanks
[Laughter]
have you gone my turn all right you see
that sweet stunt anyways thanks for
sticking around to the end of the
episode today's sponsor is Squarespace
and I'm gonna tell you all about how you
can get 10% off your first purchase but
first a joke a businessman a lawyer and
a dentist walk into a bar now only one
person uses Squarespace can you guess
which one it is so the answer is that
it's the bartender and the bartender is
the real winner here he was able to
create a beautiful website that got the
dentist the lawyer and the businessman
into his bar in the first place because
he used the beautiful award-winning
templates that Squarespace has another
thing that bartender did is he posted
about his awesome bar on Squarespace and
it did simultaneous posting on to his
Twitter profile the next thing that
savvy bartender did is allow multiple
contributors to contribute to his
website he didn't just create the whole
website himself he had one of the
waiters get in on the action he had a
mixologist get on the action and you
might be wondering wow it's really hard
to get dentists into bars these days but
using squarespace's traffic overview
system this savvy bartender was able to
understand a little extra about his
marketing techniques to get them in
their mouthwash shots anyone we all know
it's super easy to get lawyers into bars
I mean trust me but one thing you might
not know is that it's really hard for
lawyers to pass the bar and it's even
more difficult to get lawyers out of
bars unless they commit malpractice
using iron bars think about that one but
anyway what you probably should know is
that this savvy bartender talks to all
those lawyers in his bar and he found
out all the stuff that he posts on his
Squarespace website belongs to him
that's because Squarespace gives
content ownership over everything you
post on their platform and now finally
let's make sure we talk about that
business man that business man well he's
the smartest one of the bunch because he
went on over to squarespace.com slash
corridor crew and he got 10% off his
first purchase that's right
squarespace.com slash corridor crew get
10% off your first purchase hey guys its
Lucas I wanted to let you guys know
about my favorite Instagram account
that's at corridor digital you know we
have this pretty sweet face filtered
that red made maybe you can look as cool
as me